Transcriber: Eman Adel
المدقّق: Riyad Altayeb
(موسيقى)
سمك القرش.
من منا يخاف من أسماك القرش؟
جيد.
قد يكون السؤال غريباً قليلاً.
لكنني قد رأيت بعض الأشياء الغريبة،
التي جعلتني أسأل نفسي هذا السؤال.
سأخبركم بعض المعلومات. جامعة فلوريدا،
التي تنشر الإحصائيات المشهورة في العالم،
هي التي أعطت هذه المعلومات.
أتعلمون كم يقتل سمك القرش شخصًا سنوياً؟
ستة أشخاص.
أتعرفون جوز الهند؟
ثمرة بنية اللون وصلبة قليلاً.
توجد في الأماكن الإستوائية، كأي ثمرة أخرى
تسقط عن الشجرة، قد تقتل من تسقط على رأسه.
أتعلمون كم يقتل جوز الهند سنوياً؟
مائة وخمسون شخصاً.
أي بالأرقام، جوز الهند أخطر من أسماك القرش
أتعلمون كم يقتل البشر من سمك القرش سنوياً؟
مائة مليون سمكة.
سبعون مليوناً تُقطع زعانفهم لصُنع الحساء،
وتُرمى السمكة حية في الماء تنزف حتى الموت.
الثلاثون مليوناً الآخرون، إما يتم اصطيادهم
خطأً، لأنه يوجد شباك لاصطياد سمك كثير.
وبما أن سمك القرش أكبرهم
فهو الذي يتم صيده،
ثم يُرمى مرة أخرى في الماء بعد نفوقه كهادر
أو،
تلويثنا للماء جعل بيته غير قابل للحياة
فإذا تحدثنا بعقلانية،
على سمك القرش الخوف منا،
ليس نحن من علينا الخوف منهم.
إذاً لم نخاف جداً من أسماك القرش هكذا؟
الحقيقة هي أنه منذ عمل فيلم
"الفك المفترس" Jaws في 1975
كان رد فعل الناس هو رعب غير طبيعي من القرش
وقد أحبت الناس هذا الرعب وأحبت هذا النوع
من أفلام الرعب،
لذا قررت صناعة السنيما
نشر أفلام كثيرة من نفس النوع،
وعند نشر كل فيلم جديد عن سمك القرش،
كان يحدث شيئان:
الشيء الأول هو أن رعب الناس يزداد،
الشيء الثاني هو أنَ صيد أسماك القرش
وصل لمعدلات غير مسبوقة،
حتى وصل اليوم لمائة مليون قرش يموت سنوياً،
ما يأخذنا لدرس مهم جداً، هو تأثير الإعلام
على تصرفاتنا وسلوكنا تجاه شيء معين،
والصورة الذهنية التي يرسمها في أدمغتنا.
التي من الممكن أن يكون فيها شيء من الصحة،
ومن الممكن أن تحتوي على كثير من المبالغة.
وفي كثير من الأوقات
تكون عارية تمامًا من الصحة،
والدليل:
أتعرفون هذه السمكة؟
هذه السمكة تدعى أوركا،
هذه الأوركا نراها سمكة جميلة جداً،
وعند رؤيتها بالماء سننبهر
وسنفرح لرؤية شيء جميل في الماء،
وهو معاكس تماماً لرد فعلنا عند رؤية القرش.
سنكون في منتهى الرعب حتى إن كنا فوق سفينة.
هذه السمكة تدعى الحوت القاتل،
لماذا؟ لأنها على رأس الهرم الغذائي،
بمعنى أنها تأكل ولا تُؤكل.
أي أنها تستطيع أكل أي كائن موجود في البحر
بما فيه سمك القرش.
ليس فقط تستطيع قتل وأكل أسماك القرش،
بل حتى قتل وأكل الحوت الأزرق
أكبر كائن يعيش الآن عرفه البشر.
أي أن هذا الكائن خلفنا، هو أكثر كائن مميت
عرفه البشر يعيش معنا اليوم،
من بدأ ولو قليلاً
بتغيير وجهة نظره عن سمكة القرش والأوركا؟
فليرفع يده
حسناً.
ألم أغير وجهة نظر عدد من الحاضرين؟
إذا أخرج أحدكم هاتفه المحمول وقام بعمل بحث
كم شخصاً تقتل سمكة الأوركا سنويا؟
حاليًا، حوالي أربعة أو خمسة أشخاص،
لكن ليس سنوياً.
أربعة أوخمسة هو إجمالي عدد الناس التي
ماتت بسبب الأوركا على مدار تاريخ البشر.
هل أخاف الآن من القرش أم الأوركا؟
الحقيقة هي أنك إذا فهمت تأثير الإعلام
على الصورة الذهنية التي تُكونها في دماغك
المؤثرة على تصرفاتك،
سوف تعلم
أن أي رسالة ستصلك
من فيديو تراه على فيسبوك، أو يوتيوب،
أوخبر تقرأه، أوأصدقائك، أو حتى شخص يكلمك
من على مسرح TEDx،
سوف تعلم أنه يجب عليك التأكد من المعلومة
أوالرسالة التي تصلك من أكثر من مصدر،
وحينها أنت من ستشكل قرارك.
أتخاف من القرش أم من الأوركا
أم لا تخاف من الأساس.
حسناً، أنا أقول أن سمك القرش ليس مؤذياً
بهذا القدر.هل أستطيع السباحة بجانبه
بدون أن يؤذيني أو أؤذيه؟
سأعرض صوراً الآن،
هذه الصور جميعها من مصر،
من البحر الأحمر لدينا.
ومن أعطوني الصور
الحمد لله هم أحياء يرزقون الآن،
والحمد لله أيضاً، لا يوجد عضات
في أي جزء من أجسادهم.
لكي تستطيع أن تسبح مع سمك القرش،
يجب أن تفهم متى يهجم سمك القرش، ولماذا؟
نحن كبشر،
لحم الإنسان ليس لذيذاً بالنسبة لسمك القرش،
لا يحب لحم الإنسان،
وفي نفس الوقت يعد الإنسان
كبيراً جداً في الحجم ليكون فريسة
لكن توجد أشياء أخرى تستفزه ليهجم أو يقتل
إذا فهمنا تلك الأشياء، سنتمكن من السباحة
بجانب سمكة القرش دون أن يؤذيني أو أؤذيه.
حسناً، ما فائدة هذا الكلام؟
إن فهم القرش أدى إلى خلق
ما يسمى سياحة القرش،
أي أن الناس تأتي من كل أنحاء العالم لتسبح
مع القرش، فتدفع وتنتج دخلاً سياحياً للبلد،
وهذا يقودنا لدرس آخر مهم جداً،
فهم الطرف الآخر وسبب تصرفاته،
حتى وإن كانت عدائية،
لا يسمح فقط بتجنب عداوته،
بل يسمح لي أيضاً بمعرفة الطريقة الأمثل
للتعاون معه لنصل معًا لأكبر استفادة ممكنة.
في الحقيقة فهم الإعلام
وتأثيره على الناس،ى وفهم الطرف الآخر
والتصرف بناءً على هذا الفهم،
غير لي حياتي أنا شخصياً
في مراحل كثيرة عشتها.
من هنا لا يزال يدرس في الجمعة أو المدرسة؟
ما شاء الله.
أنتم أكثر ناس قد تشعرون بما سأحكيه الآن،
حين كنت أدرس، كنت مبذراً جداً،
أصرف أموالي يمينًا ويسارًا،
وقد أشتري أشياء ليس لها فائدة،
ثم تُرمى، ولابد من لبس العلامات التجارية.
أهلى بدأوا يلاحظوا هذ التصرفات،
قرروا تخفيض مصروفي،
وفي بعض الأحيان حرماني من الأموال نهائياً.
شجارات في المنزل يومياً،
وحين أتحدث إلى أصدقائي،
يشتكون أيضاً من أهاليهم.
"اسمع، لن نسافر إلى الساحل هذا الأسبوع،
فقد غضب أهلي مني وأخذوا مني السيارة".
"اسمع، أهلي رجعيين جداً،
فقد عاقبوني بشدة،
عندما علموا أنني أصاحب فتاةً".
حسناً، سألتُ نفسي،
لن أستطيع أن أكمل هكذا كثيراً،
ليس من مستفيد، لا أنا ولا أهلي،
كلانا خاسر.
ماذا يمكنني أن أفعل بنفسي
كي يغير الواقع الذي أعيشه؟
فقررت أن أخفض من صرفي قليلاً.
كلما خفضت من صرفي،
كلما اقتنعت أكثر أنني كنت مبذراً،
ولم أشعر بالنعمة التي أمتلكها.
قل طلبي للمال بالمنزل، وعليه قلت الشجارات
وبالتالي بدأنا نتقبل بعضنا البعض أكثر،
حتى -الحمد لله- أصبحت علاقتنا جميلة جدا
حتى وصلنا لمرحلة أنهم يقولون لي
"يا بني خذ مالاً"، فأقول لهم "لا، شكراً
لا أحتاجها".
بعد فترة، أتت ثورة 25 يناير،
وكنت حينها مازلت أدرس بالجامعة،
مثلنا كمثل كل الشباب،
كنا متحمسين أن نفعل شيئاً مفيداً للبلد
في النطاق الذي نحن فيه، والذي كان الكلية،
فقررنا أن ندخل في مجال الأنشطة.
وقد كنا في جامعة حكومية، أي مؤسسة حكومية،
فكلما أردنا فعل شيءٍ،
وجب علينا أخذ إمضاء شخص ما
وموافقة هيئةٍ ما على شي ما،
وإقرار مجلس ما بأننا لا نخالف اللائحة
لأن وزارة المالية يمكن أن تتهمنا
بإهدار المال العام.
أي مال عام أنا مجرد طالب،
فقررنا أن نحاول استخدام
الأساتذة الجامعيين بعض الشيءء
المسئولين وقتها ليساعدوننا،
وفعلاً كانوا يساعدوننا صراحةً،
ولكن كانت توجد لوائح وروتين كثير جدًا
حولنا كان يمنعنا من تنفيذ أي شئ نريده.
حينها فقط بدأت أفهم ما يعنيه
مسئول في مؤسسة حكومية،
قد يريد حقاً عمل شيء لكنه مكتوف الأيدي
بسبب اللوائح والروتين من حوله.
ومن ضمن الأنشطة التي كنا نقوم بها
كثير ما يفشل وكثير ما ينجح.
الأشياء التي كانت تفشل، كانت تحمل وعوداً
للطلبة بأشياء معينة لم تتم،
بالنسبة للطالب الذي وُعد بشيء ولم يتم،
هذه بالنسبة له عضة.
فكان رد فعلهم إخراج شائعات على الكلية،
والجامعة وأساتذة الجامعة وأنا شخصياً،
كان يُقال عني أنني متواطئ مع الإدارة
لأننا كنا ندفع أموالاً، وترفض الكلية دفعها
في شيء حتى يتمكنوا من أخذ كل هذه الأموال
سألت نفسي أيحدث هذا معي؟
في مؤسسة وهي الجامعة حيث
كل الناس فيها على مستوى من الفكر والعلم،
فما بلك ببلد،
حكومة،
تتعامل مع جميع مؤسسات
الدولة وتتعامل مع جميع المستويات الفكرية.
إذا كنتُ اليوم في مكان مسئول،
ماذا سأفعل؟
حسناً إذا كنت أعيش في بلد أصدرت قراراً
أنا أرى أنه قام بعضي،
أو يؤذيني أو أراه غير مفهوم،
كمثال هل ذهب أحد إلى سنغافورة؟
يوجد اثنان بالخلف
واحد
ما شاء الله.
إذا ما ذهب أحدكم إلى سنغافورة
وبحث عن علكة في المحلات فلن يجد،
ولن يعطيه أحد علكة
كبديل عن الباقي من مال الشراء،
لأن الحكومة السنغافورية
قد قررت أن تمنع العلكة من سنغافورة،
فأنا كشخص يرى هذا الخبر
من الخارج،
أفكر هل الحكومة السنغافورية متفرغة جدًا
لدرجة ان تمنع العلكة! ألم تجد غيره لتمنعه.
لكن ما رأيته بالكلية يحجث معي
وإشاعات عني بسبب خبرهم يسمعونه
دون التأكد من الدوافع أو صحة هذا الخبر،
جعلني أحاول معرفة، ماذا كانت دوافع
الحكومة السنغافورية لمنع العلكة؟
فاكتشفت أن الناس كانت تلقيه
على الأرض بعد مضغه فيلتصق ويسبب بقعًا
مما جعل الحكومة تصرف ملايين الدولارات
سنوياً لتنظيف هذه البقع،
فقررت منع العلكة.
الكثير بسنغافورة أيد هذا القرار،
لأن الحكومة توفر،
والكثير عارض،
لأن العلكة صناعة تشغل الناس
عمالة، تُدخل اقتصاد،
فمن أخبرك أنَه عند غلق صناعة بالكامل
سيكون أفضل من بضعة الملايين التي توفرها،
كان يمكن لصانعي العلكة في سنغافورة
أن تنزل لعمل مظاهرات،
وفي العديد من البلاد قد ثبُت
أن المظاهرات ليست دائماً هي الحل الأمثل
مع أنها في بعض الأحيان
تكون فعلاً الحل الأمثل،
لكن صانعي العلكة في سنغافورة
فعلوا شيئًا مختلفًا قليلًا،
فقد تمكنوا من التنسيق
مع أكبر مصنعي العلكة في العالم
فأحضروهم بحكوماتهم
للتفاوض مع الحكومة السنغافورية
حتى توصلوا لحل،
وهو أنه يمكن بيع العلكة،
ولكن العلكة الطبية فقط بالصيدليات.
لو كانت الناس التي عُضت
من قرار الحكومة السنغافورية
لا تعي دوافع القرار،
ما تمكنت أبداً من اختيار الطريقة الصحيحة
التي تؤدي للوصول لحل وسط يرضي الجميع.
نفس الكلام يمكن تطبيقه
على قرارات كثيرة جداً
أُُخذت في دول عديدة في العالم،
كدول تقنن الحشيش،
أو حكومات التي تبيح زواج المثليين،
أو حكومات تقبض على متظاهرين،
أوحكومات تمنع استيراد سلعة معينة
قد تدمر حياة البعض.
فإذا كنت أحد المتضررين من هذه القرارت
من الممكن حين تفهم
دوافع الحكومة لأخذ هذا القرار،
أن تبدأ في تغيير رأيك،
حتى إن لم تغير رأيك،
على الأقل ستعرف الطريقة الصحيحة
للتفاهم مع حكومة البلد التي تعيش فيها
حتى تستطيع التوصل لحل،
من دون لن تستطيع الوصول معهم لحل.
وبعد فترة،
كبرت وعملت بأكثر من شركة.
كم شخص يوجد هنا يعمل؟
حسناً،
كم شخص يوجد هنا يحب عمله؟
ما شاء الله،
أنتم لا تُصوروا، للعلم.
حسناً.
عندما بدأت أعمل في أحد الشركات،
كان علي حمل كبير جداً
أكثر من قدرة أى شخص على التحمل،
كمية عمل هائلة،
فلم أمتلك القدرة على إنهاء العمل
وكانت جودته غير مقبولة،
لم أكن أجيب على رسائل البريد الإلكتروني
أو المكالمات،
فقررت أن أشتكي للمدير.
وكانت هذه إحدى أكبر الأخطاء التي ارتكبتها.
فقد قال لي المدير: "أنت الذي لديه المشكلة"
"أنت الذي لا تستطيع تنظيم وقتك
أو تحدد أولوياتك".
مهما حاولت إقناعه بلا جدوى.
وقال لي: "ليس في مصلحتك أن تكمل هكذا".
سألت العديد من الأشخاص فأخبروني:
"نعم، فجميع المديرين هكذا، يلقي اللوم
عليك حتى لا يُظهر أنه لا يعرف كيف يتصرف".
دائماً ما تظهر الأفلام والمسلسلات
المدير أنه البعبع،
ودائماً ما يكون هو هادم اللذات.
سألت نفسي مرة أخرى:
لن أتمكن من الاستمرارهكذا
فماذا يمكنني أن أفعل في نفسي
لتغيير الواقع الذي كنت أعيشه؟
فقررت عرض المشكلة
عليه بطريقة مختلفة قليلاً،
فقمت بعمل قائمة بالمهام المطلوب عملها
وكم تستغرق كل مهمة من الوقت،
فأتضح أنني بحاجة لأربع ساعات يوميًا
أكثرمن فترة عملي لإكمال العمل المطلوب مني،
حين عرضت المشكلة على مديري
بهذه الطريقة بدأ بالاستماع،
فأخبرته بأن المخاطر التي قد تنتج عن ذلك
أني لن أنهي العمل بالجودة المطلوبة،
ذلك إذا انتهى،
كما أني لن أجد الوقت للرد
إذا ما وُجدت مشكلة.
الحل - أنا وزملائي كنا نعاني
من نفس المشكلة،
ومن الممكن تعيين شخص جديد
حتى تتوزع المهام بشكل جيد،
اكتشفت فيما بعد أن الشركة تقوم فعلًا
بهذه الدراسة ولكن في نهاية العام،
وبما أنني كنت جديداً لم أكن أعلم
فقمت بعمل الشيء الذي يفهمه المدير
ويعرف كيف يتقبلها ويناقشه، فحينها أقتنع،
ورفع هذه الدراسة إلى الإدارة العليا،
والإدارة العليا -
حين رأت أنَه توجد مشكلة عند بعض الموظفين -
طلبت أن تتم هذه الدراسة على الشركة ككل،
وحين قامت بعمل الدراسة،
اكتشفوا وجود مشكلة فعلاً.
وقامت بعمل خطة تعيينات على أساسها
ثم تم فعلاً تعيين أشخاص،
وتوزعت المهام جيداً.
وفي النهاية، الحمد لله، لم أحصل فقط على
رد فعل إيجابي بل وتم تنفيذ كل ما طلبته.
فهم الإعلام وتأثيره،
وفهم الطرف الآخر
والتصرف بناءً على هذا الفهم غير لي حياتي
في كل ما أخبرتكم به.
كما يمكن للأهل أن يعضوا في المنزل
عن طريق العقاب أو الحرمان من المال،
كما يمكن للحكومة أن تعض عن طريق
إصدار قرار لا يعجبك أو تقبض عليك،
وكما يمكن للمدير في العمل أن يعض
عن طريق مضايقتك أو رفدك
كالقرش الذي قد يعضك وأنت في الماء،
وقد يقتلك.
إذا ما نزل شخص ما إلى ماء يوجد به قرش وهو
على علم، فلا يقع اللوم على القرش إذا عضه،
بل يقع اللوم على الشخص الذي نزل إلى الماء
وتعامل مع القرش دون أن يفهم كيف يتعامل معه
فلا تجعل عضة قرشٍ تلهيك
عن التصرف الذي يجب عليك فعله.
شكراً.
(تصفيق).
(موسيقى)